Поки наймолодший з новообраних депутатів Верховної Ради,
23-річний Святослав Юраш, чепуриться перед дзеркалом…
…його дружина, 22-річна Софія, хазяйнує на кухні.
Ну, чорна ікра, креветки, що там… Ще треба на березі Мальдів.
Але оскільки ми будемо чесними депутатами, не я,
а Свят буде чесним депутатом, то просто буде фруктовий сніданок.
За сніданком обговорюють результати парламентських виборів:
цього разу українці обрали понад 320 депутатів,
які раніше там не працювали.
Таке очищення парламенту Святослав називає історичним моментом та ...
… революція без крові
Сам же 27-ий у списку партії "Слуга народу" стане
наймолодшим депутатом за всю історію парламенту.
Попри юний вік Святослав має чималий досвід:
під час Революції Гідності заснував Міжнародний центр Майдану
та семимовний медіаресурс EuromaidanPR.
Був секретарем громадської ради при
парламентському комітеті у закордонних справах.
І от тепер народний депутат України...
У них у всіх колись не було досвіду депутатства, я не впевнена,
що є якась школа депутатів, університет депутатів…
Депутат - це комунікатор між експертами і народом.
Народом і експертами. Депутат має завдання номер один
- бути тим, хто будує коаліції, роз'яснює...
Цю затишну квартиру з високими стелями родина знімає з квітня.
Знаходиться в самому центрі урядового кварталу Києва - на Шовковичній.
Вартість оренди оплачує дружина.
З 13 років Софія захоплюється косплеєм.
Це театральний перформанс за участі героїв аніме.
Для них шиє костюми і має клієнтів по всьому світу.
Від чоловіка-депутата вагітна Софія чекає
не стільки грошей, скільки доленосних рішень.
Через війну змушена була залишити рідний Донецьк.
Тож, хоче, аби нова Рада почала повертати окуповані території.
Я думаю, вони будуть інформаційну підтримку дуже велику намагатись…
Да, малеча, тебе теж це хвилює.
Що ти думаєш з приводу Донбасу?
Але це київська киця, вона на Донбасі не була.
Інформаційна підтримка буде.
Я думаю, вони будуть якось проукраїнську інформацію
доставляти якось до людей, щоб починати діалог.
Перше урочисте засідання, де він разом з іншими
депутатами складе присягу, очевидно відбудеться
24 серпня - в день Незалежності України.
Поки ж молодий політик звикає бути в центрі уваги
журналістів та часто жовтої преси.
Що я прессекретар Яроша. Вимальовують теореми про те,
що я не маю середньої освіти, бо я з 14 років
поїхав в Індію на навчання і так далі...
Але це смішно, звичайно...
Ці всі титули "весільні фотографи" і всі інші титули,
які мені давали також - це є частина бруду,
яким зараз обливають і нас в тому числі.
Святослав щиро вірить у добрі наміри політичної
партії "Слуга народу" та президента Зеленського,
який зміг зафарбувати мапу всієї України в єдиний зелений колір.
Хоча зараз деякі ініціативи президента, як от
розширення люстрації на чиновників часів Порошенка,
критикують, зокрема і посли країн "Великої сімки".
Не бачить конфлікту інтересів Святослав і в
призначенні адвоката олігарха Ігоря Коломойського
на посаду голови Офісу президента.
Я так не вважаю. Пан Богдан, людина яка була в системі,
яка була нею, на мою думку, пережована і викинута.
Він - людина, яка може бути корисною, бути в
процесі трансформації системи і тому пан Богдан є людина,
яка для тої позиції, якою є голова Офісу Президента,
є людиною дуже доброю.
Творчістю Зеленського-актора хлопець особливо не цікавився.
Серіал "Слуга народу" дивився лише за порадою дружини.
Випуски "Кварталу 95" бачив теж зрідка.
Втім, йому імпонує те, як комік висміював українську реальність.
Жарти про Львів зап’ятались… про те, як
у нас маскують всі проблеми патріотичністю…
Дорогою до офісу партії хлопець розповідає,
яким депутатом не хоче бути…
Коли в парламенті показують на великому табло,
як депутати беруть хабарі і потім ці депутати
судяться в Європейському суді за компенсацію.
Такий сюр не має більше існувати.
В першу чергу зняття недоторканності і зняття
ореолу з депутатських реалій і для нас
перше завдання - рубати собі крила.
Скільки буде отримувати, ставши народним депутатом, не знає.
Зарплата народних обранців коливається від 17 тисяч до 40 тисяч гривень.
Втім, на деякі пільги таки розраховує.
А я не з Києва, а зі Львова. Там є ще пільги або жити
в готелі "Київ", або пільги на квартиру.
Ось цей варіант. Я чув, що Феофанія - лікарня
непогана і в контексті того, що дружина
буде народжувати було б добре мати лікарню.
У період розпалу літніх відпусток команда Святослава
в офісі партії працює над законопроектом
про реформу дипломатичної служби та МЗС,
який, на їхню думку, має посилити позиції України у світі.
Розуміє, що це, можливо, і не перші зміни,
на які чекають українці, але важливі
для боротьби на міжнародній арені.